This could be a Halloween costume right here.  Girl that checks Pinterest too much.
Hi! My name is Grace Helbig. If you do not know, now you know; your life is different now.
I've done two of these videos already so time for a third.
It's more YouTuber Halloween costumes that you can make for really cheap
with most of the stuff that you already have in your home.
If you missed the other two, go back and watch them.  They were fun.
Here are five YouTuber Halloween costumes that I made using five items each costume.
Costume #1
For this costume, you're going to need some sort of hipster, pixie outfit, like a dress or a skirt that makes you look like you .. don't hurt people.
Then we need some thick, messy brown hair.  You don't care what it looks like because you have art to make with your feelings.
We also need some fuller brown eyebrows.
A ukulele
And God given music talent with an ability to be chaotically whimsical, relatable, and vulnerable all at once!
Ta da! You're Dodie Clark! (sound effect: oooooo)
Costume #2
For this costume, you're going to need some cheeky tossled, blonde boy hair.
I don't have that kind of wig, so I'm just going to fake it by spraying and pinning my hair back.
Then you're going to need some cheeky chill boys' clothes.
Maybe a cheeky chill Sugg life sweatshirt.
Or a cheeky chill ripoff if you have a pink sweatshirt and some iron-on letters are your disposal.
Then all we need is a cheeky chill wry smile and an endless desire for cheeky mischief that leads you to build a chill and charming empire.
Ta da!  You're Joe Sugg!  (sound effect: oh noooo!)
Quick modification: if you take your hair down and put on a dark lip...
Ta da!  You're Zoella Sugg! (sound effect: oooo)
Costume #3
For this costume, we need some heavier makeup with a fun lip color but also no eyebrows.
The classic sweatshirt, choker combo
You're also going to need some long hair that has possible shades of every color on the spectrum in it.
A pair of dogs that I personally have a conspiracy theory that they're actually aliens pretending to be dogs
And a brain that operates simultaneously as a perverted teenage boy and an introspective adult psych major
with a desire for the constant dumb
Look at that, you're Jenna Marbles! (sound effect: woah!)
Costume #4
For this costume, you're going to need some sort of black and white outfit. Maybe a striped shirt.
Then some short dark curly hair. (This is the best I could do; please don't get mad.)
Multiple personalities.
She doesn't have multiple personalities, she just has a lot of time on her hands.
That personality's right - this is a lot of time.
A strong affinity for word play
And a bunch of friends riding your coat tails. Just kidding! Ta da! You're Liza Koshy! (sound effect: yeaaah)
And costume #5
For this costume you need a generic boy sweater/sweatshirt/t-shirt,
short brown boy hair - very Beatles-esque,
toys in your background,
a cat nose and whiskers drawn crudely on your face
and a militia-esque fan base of teenage girls primarily that would literally kill and die for you.
Ta da!  You're Dan and/or Phil! (sound effect: crying)
So there ya go! There are five more YouTuber Halloween costume ideas for you.  Let me know in the comments down below which was your favorite.
And what are you being for Halloween?  Those of you who live in countries that celebrate Halloween.
I care. Really. I do. We're having a dialogue. It's what makes new media different than traditional media.
Let's engage, shall we?
That was my impression of a social media influencer in Westworld.
If you liked this video, give it a thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube Channel if you haven't already.
Click that bell notification so you know when I post videos.  They're supposed to be Monday, Wednesday, and Friday but that's only sometimes. Other than that...
I don't know.
Can you guys guess what my Halloween costume is?
Annoying girl.
The girl at the party that keeps trying to get people to take candid photos of her.
Her whole Instagram theme is: I don't look at the camera and I'm constantly caught in the middle of a big laugh!
She's fun.